[Music]
welcome to episode who gives a
so as you can see we're grilling that
connect today don't do it
I love you doesn't seem to be working so
we'll grill him in a bit oh thank god
I was like oh I'm done opening all mail
get on me how this best for us what is
all today I'm gonna I'm gonna take this
one price because it has a moment all
this on there I guess this is supposed
to be me and this is supposed to be my
sound I got a friend
thank you for sending me Barbie dolls
that's really nice of you
earrings I can totally wear these it's
beautiful goodbye from federica's
cannelloni she drop face on it okay
thank you I always wanted to be loved by
a potatoes you know
I'll kill that potato the father guys no
way oh yeah - alright bipolar be a how's
it going bro
it's the portrait bueno well it did
Brian I I'm a bro from Spain and I love
your videos you always make them smile
so no matter how hard my dick no matter
how fun it is
I really want to thank you for that
Bryce Thank You Paula
I like the little detail with that me
and plenty clear can't wait for episode
all right breast since I didn't have
that much mail to open I'm doing a Q&A
so I asked two bros on Twitter ask me
anything and
[Music]
and I'll answer it a kilo Joe asked me
what are you planning to do it after you
are done with YouTube I think if there's
something that I learned from YouTube
it's that I'm a creative person and I
want to make stuff so there's a lot of
things that I want to go into and I
think YouTube is opening up a lot of
possibilities for me especially how
things are going right now so as long as
I enjoy making videos I'm gonna keep
making videos and that doesn't seem to
change anytime soon
so don't worry breath Alif cry Donna did
you have good marks in high school is
everyone asking let's go
I don't really go that much to high
school I just wanted to go home and play
video games pretty much that was me
during high school I did have good
grades to get into university I think
you needed I think you need highest
grade and everything to get into the the
line of university that I went to doing
youtube as my job is really a dream
coming true I made a video explaining
about it I can show you down there it
was really such a happy moment but I can
realize that I am I could first of all I
could stay with my girlfriend because
she's from Italy and you know getting a
job for me and Italy would be really
difficult so there are so many things
and that user has already opened up for
me and it's just made my life you know
completely different than I I never been
this happy ever
and I feel like I'm finally living life
as it should be you know I'm doing what
I actually love to do and yeah so I have
you bros to thank for that I'm taking
way too much time on each question Cory
will you play Resident Evil 6 no it
seems kind of cool it just doesn't
interest me
I'm sorry Benzer Morgan how long have
you and Marcin been together over a year
I think something like that
my longest relationship Paul when are
you going to make another scary moments
video um I think this weekend would be a
good good time to get one out maybe I
should try to edit one and have it done
for Sunday remind me on Sunday if you
don't see it just tell me I suck Emily
if you had a loading screen like heavy
rain how would it look something like
that how many times you've isn't home in
a year I only been away for like half a
year and I've been home one time I miss
Sweden oh I miss Swedish food I miss my
friends I miss my family
I might actually returned to Sweden for
a couple days soon bras in case you
wonder where the hell I go Deb
do you cook what is your favorite food
or dish I make the best pancakes the
pier the pie pancakes
you want some how much time do you spend
making this video I take a lot of time I
think it takes a lot more time than
people actually think cuz I do it seven
days a week more or less it depends it
depends a lot on each day I'd say never
age like 7 to 7 to 12 hours each day
Jack Sparrow people seem to think you
and Tobuscus are competing what's your
take a knife I don't really compete with
anyone on YouTube I just make videos
because I want to entertain people and
you know competition or fans fighting or
anything like that I'm I'm really not in
that's not why I'm here that's not why
I'm making videos
Shannon Cameron in a zombie apocalypse
what weapon choice would you choose and
choose like one of those knives that
goes around here and then goes out there
they're kind of like a tiny bulla Burra
and I would just cuz that's look weird
no that's what I would have I don't
remember what it's called I might look
it up brands like are you a duck yes
Batman are you actually a duck yes
slender man how do you feel about the
whole crime peuta cry thing i people
want to make up fun things I don't
really mind at all to be honest it
doesn't really bother me I'm thinking
both me and cry are kind of comfortable
with ourself enough to just you know
kinda laugh at it I guess it's not
something that we'd take too seriously
alright that's pretty much it for this
Friday wrap I hope you enjoyed it you
know what this is you don't want me
neither
just kidding this is what it is anyway
thanks for all your support bros it's
really what makes YouTube fun for me I
only make these videos for you stay
awesome you know I love you it's time
David are you ready
alright on the count of three one two
breathe ha ha ha ha sorry I'm here we
got breath
[Music]
it'll cry hey hey hey come here
let me wipe your tears